[موسيقى]
بينما كان السباق لإنهاء جناح سنغافورة
قيد التنفيذ ،
يتم استخدام الابتكار الحضري الذكي لجلب
رؤية جاردن سيتي إلى إكسبو ودبي ،
حيث ترى الأولاد هناك
، وعادة ما يكونون على ناطحة سحاب في
دبي  45000 من النباتات
التي تُزرع على الشجرة الخضراء المخروطية بالأسفل
هنا ،
إنها مهمة دقيقة يتم وضع كل نبات
بعناية في أواني في هياكل ضخمة تشبه المخروط ،
يتم نقل النباتات التي يمكن أن تتحمل أشعة الشمس القاسية في دبي إلى الأمام بينما تكون
أكثر هشاشة.  يضمن وضعها في
تقنية الظل أن يحصل كل منها على
الكمية الدقيقة من الماء التي تتطلبها
ما تراه هنا عبارة عن أنبوب يتم
إدخاله في التربة وسيقوم بسقي
التربة ، وقد
تم حسابها جميعًا
بعناية فائقة حتى
تصبح النباتات المختلفة مختلفة  كمية المياه التي
لا تنتهي بها التكنولوجيا هناك
، يتم استخدام الروبوتات لفحص صحة المصنع
ولجمع البيانات البيئية عن
مدى استدامة الجزء العلوي من
المظلة الشمسية الضخمة و compris  وحدات من 517
لوحًا شمسيًا توفر مظلات للجناح
وأسفل الأسفل نقوم أيضًا بسحب المياه
الجوفية وتحلية المياه الجوفية
لاستخدام الجناح ،
لذلك نهدف إلى الحصول على اكتفاء ذاتي
يحتوي على جناح مغلق بدون طاقة
طوال فترة الستة أشهر من
خلال  باستخدام التصميم الذكي
لمظلة شمسية وآلاف من النباتات ،
يزعم المصممون أن درجة الحرارة
ستنخفض بمقدار 10 درجات داخل الكل
لإثبات وجهة نظر سنغافورة بأنه من خلال
التقنيات المستدامة يمكننا التعايش
مع الطبيعة
مع الابتكارات الحضرية الذكية أعتقد
أن ذلك يمكن تحقيقه بغض النظر عن
المناخ سواء كان في المناطق الاستوائية أو
في
حالة الصحراء
على الرغم من التأخير لمدة عام
بسبب الوباء العالمي مع الحدث
الجاري أخيرًا للأشهر الستة المقبلة.
دبي